l'union avec la tête mais il dit oui
avec le choeur l'hymne ont dit oui à ce
qu'ils aiment et ils guinot professeur
le cancre de jacques prévert un
classique dans les écoles françaises
depuis plusieurs générations
debout face à la classe qui n'a pas
réciter par coeur les célèbres vers du
poème ce en 1981 auprès de ses enfants
il faisait l'unanimité aimez-vous
jacques prévert qui connaît lé pour
faire le portrait d'un oiseau lever la
main oh là là il y en a pas mal
alors qui va nous le dire attends toi tu
veux on t'écoute confère la partie la
moins d'agir d'abord une cage avec une
importe quel est le secret de prévert un
langage familier des thèmes accessibles
à tous c'est parfois ça ce qu'on appelle
la police fait par des gens qu'on
connaît pas n'importe où des gens qui
dorment dans la rue
aucune invention comme ça un tas
d'enfants et d'argent 1 agde hérault
qu'il débloque dans la rue sans le
savoir et fait l'apologie
une philosophie qui séduisait cette
enseignante en 1973 et entre les poèmes
de jacques prévert et les fables de jean
de la fontaine son choix était vite fait
je pense que le fait de la fontaine par
exemple a vieilli certaines phrases ne
se comprennent plus les élèves le dise
roma d'amendé contre auriel alors
personnellement je préfère un prêt vert
nous apprenons donc de poèmes de prévert
je trouve que c'est plus facile et puis
c'est du français un avis partagé
quelques années plus tôt par ce jeune
garçon on a tellement rabâché a condamné
puis c'est toujours pareil on prend
d'arcachon sculptant les rapides puis il
ya une chanson ya toutes les chansons
l'autre arme de séduction de jacques
prévert il en a écrit des dizaines sans
compter ses poèmes qui parfois devenait
aussi des chansons
enfants sous la iiième j'habitais au
quatrième maison du 19e lors été sur le
palier parfois le gaz a été coupé et
souvent les enquêteurs de la semeuse
cogner à la porte en porte alors en
chanson ou en poésie les mots de prévert
résonne encore dans les écoles
françaises et preuve de sa popularité
près de 500 établissements porte son nom
aujourd'hui
[Musique]